an independent investigation released
today has found Scottish Cricket to be
institutionally racist the report cites
at least 448 examples that prove
discrimination to be heavily rooted in
the sport the entire Board of cricket
Scotland resigned yesterday after Sky
News broke the investigation's findings
well let's have a look at the headlines
for you now the report revealed that 62
percent of all survey respondents had
experienced seen or reported to them
incidents of racism inequalities or
discrimination there was a lack of any
anti-racist training in place for board
staff volunteers players coaches or
umpires and there was no consistent
process for handling racist incidents
and people who did raise issues were
sidelined or ignored
well I'll correspondent James Matthews
broke the story for us over the weekend
he joins me now with the very latest
James so a seven month investigation in
the making and a very damning set of
conclusions there
yeah dummy would be the world we had the
headline on Saturday didn't we that in
the institutional racism was the central
finding we have no the detail and it
doesn't make great reading for Cricket
Scotland the governing body and the game
north of the border the figures are
particularly damning this report
published this morning we'll hear from
its authors fairly shortly it speaks of
448 indicators of institutional racism
the way that researchers worked on this
they drew up 31 indicators points that
they measured Cricket Scotland again
sort of those 31 indicators Cricket
Scotland filled on 29 and the only
partially met the test on the remaining
two there were something like a thousand
people who spoke to the report authors
and they complained of a number of
things essentially racism and aggression
that ran through pretty much all levels
of the game I'll give you an example of
some of the things that those involved
in Cricket in Scotland said they
reckoned that there was an inappropriate
use of language in some cases which
would be racist considered simply as
banter they spoke of a concern that
sledging was being used as an excuse to
racially abuse opposition players there
was a lack of understanding some said of
the impact of language and behavior on
individuals inadequate systems to report
racism on and off the pitch
some complained of or some said there
was no willingness in some instances to
deal with discriminatory incidents a
lack of trust some spoke of and also a
lack of diversity of players coaches and
umpires within the game that led to a
lack of Role Models now sport Scotland
which is the governing body for sport as
a whole north of the Border it has
consistently said it would enforce the
recommendations in full one of the key
recommendations in this report is that
the cricket Scotland board you'll
remember they resigned on Mass yesterday
when a new board is set up sport
Scotland wants to see 40 percent of that
at least male 40 at least female and
also 25 coming from uh the the black
Southeast Asian or other mixed or
multiple ethnic groups of society
Cricket Scotland has been placed in
special measures essentially that means
that if those recommendations aren't
followed through by Cricket Scotland
itself then Scotland will step in and
one of the measures it may Implement is
a withholding of funding from the
cricketing body which would be extremely
bad news for uh cricket Scotland which
consistently claims under funding so you
know there will be serious consequences
if the recommendations in this report
are not followed through but essentially
following the headline over the weekend
of institutional racism the detail lays
bare a sport in Scotland in a sorry
state